I know you're an army doctor you've been
invalided home from Afghanistan and
they've got a brother who's worried
about you but you weren't go to him for
help because you didn't approve of him
possibly because he's an alcoholic more
likely because he recently walked out on
his wife and I know that your therapist
thinks your limps psychosomatic quite
correctly I'm afraid so I gotta figure
out a way to grow three years worth of
food here on a planet where nothing
grows he's the man for his time and
place he fits right in there and that's
the dude in Los Angeles this is the One
Ring forged by the Dark Lord Sauron in
the fires of my doom as far back as I
can remember I always wanted to be a
gangster
[Music]
you've been a pastor Oh have you sex my
dermatologist says keep them aerated
like that's gonna cure anything I don't
know maybe rocks I really can't tell you
ever been arrested no never dreaming
that a scheming sheriff and his posse
wasn't watching them and gathering
around to show that Nick turned
three-dimensional space into two
dimensions which turns a wormhole into
two dimensions the circle what's a
circle in three dimensions sphere your
mother got a lot of money when Travis
and Brad's father died a lot yeah ha we
know that's why we're here we shut up
I've been wondering what are
midi-chlorians
midi-chlorians are a microscopic
life-form that resides within all living
cells
this is katana she's got my back she cut
all you and a half with one sword stroke
just like on the lawn
I would advise not getting killed by her
her sword traps the souls of its victims
we're asleep our mind can be almost
anything frames they feel real while
we're in them right I think you guys
enjoy playing dress-up as much as the
guests the hosts can't hurt you by
design
[Music]
The Matrix is everywhere it is all
around us even now in this very room you
can see it when you look out your window
it's the queen she smart she fears she
move any way she want as far as she
wants and she is the go get done peace
remind me a string how many times have
we interviewed a writer in the last 10
years
take guess uh how many zero
I checked maybe because Rolling Stone
doesn't interview writers so so there I
am I'm sitting there yeah I've been on a
rostrum with this guy having leave Welty
give us an award eat two years later I'm
sitting there it's the first time I
remember ever actively like diving under
something that somebody avoid a cylinder
table yeah president-elect Garrett
Walker do I like him no do I believe in
him that's beside the point
any politician they get 70 million votes
has tapped into something larger than
himself louder than even me as much as I
hate to admit it where's the trash I'm
talking rock-bottom FICO scores no
income verification a lot of these
triple B's are going to zero - and that
you're too close is an opportunity like
crash the ground exploded and caught on
fire and I smashed on the side of a hill
with my face
I was driving home I live alone right
now anyway two joggers ran up and
started digging out all the dirt that
was jammed inside my mouth and my nose
and ears my brain and stopped my heart
it stopped so technically I was dead at
this point
they did all the procedures exactly
right as a result of which I'm still
alive
boy Wow he was listed in the city
directory as Thomas Howard and he went
everywhere unrecognized and lunched with
Kansas City shopkeepers and merchants
calling himself a cattleman or
commodities investor we have Hermine
structured Jo I had to get away from
circuitry I needed something that could
arrange and rearrange in a molecular
level but keep its form when required
how did my father die
a young Jedi named Darth Vader who was a
pupil of mine until he turned to evil
helped the Empire hunt down and destroy
the Jedi Knights he betrayed and
murdered your father
I know father
look this kid's been kicked around all
of his life you know born in a slum
mother dead since he was nine lived for
a year and a half in an orphanage one is
his father was serving a jail term for
forgery it's not have a very happy
beginning he's a a wild angry kid that's
all he's ever been and you know why cuz
he's been hit on the head by somebody
once a day every day I seen if you
showdown is my day more than you know
you
you
yeah five we know that's why we're here
we shut up shut up